I'm going to get this light in this spot
that's easier to turn
on there we
go um
quick morning
stream I just want to fix the
build me see where we were
so
now let me just redo it though to make
sure I didn't screw something up I was
working on this
light
we're just having some Linker issues
with the uh the pit package and
RB I'm hoping this doesn't take too long
today and get back to some real research
cuz I got some cool results
overnight uh
so yeah so this is this does not contain
rib
uh at
Lo if I put a I don't think I can put a
break point because I think setup tools
will screw with it
all I changed in setup.py I changed the
include doors
places more importantly why
why is rib no longer
the mean time I did get a one cool
result
here so overnight we have 58 breakout
results 58 breakout runs
and are
nice so you can see we got all these
like solved runs here
nice we're going to probably want to
Benchmark some additional algorithms I
don't know why it does this type of
stuff um
um like it just has some bad runs it
seems unless this is on the Paro front
like this point this point
maybe we'll look at that later there's
some graph like some graph types that
are just missing
here what is wrong with this
though
so building wheel
data I haven't tried this
lately does this currently work
I'm hoping this doesn't take too long
today because I have like multiple cool
things to work
on it's just packaging is a
pain we're probably going to look at
later today the Sumo traffic
simulator uh for Kathy Woo's
lab
and then there's going to be uh some
Isaac Jim
stuff uh for uh undisposed undisposed
closed client but basic integration will
be on stream
path I think it's just like a relative
path
thing because it works from um
it works from the puffer lip directory
it doesn't work
globally time is
it
9 well I think what I'll do is I'll if
this doesn't take a ridiculous amount of
time I'll do this till I fix it I'll go
grab breakfast and then we'll come back
and I'll do either Sumo trffic Sim or
some Physics stuff depending
fixes from yesterday mean that we have
long and breakout working nicely as test
environments um breakouts a bit too slow
I definitely want to look at
why that is the
case I don't think all of the runs are
too slow
though I think it's just the
settings th000
seconds 20 minutes that's still kind of
slow
H we'll have to figure out why that is
there's no frame skip or anything
so but still that seems a little weird
to me
was supposed to put a meeting on the Cal
as well I me we'll find
that I here the uh the
experiments you can see how nice it is
to have like a a sweep type thing like
this this is w b um you can add this
wherever
though and see they added the parallel
axis plots back
in
okay now does this do anything
still no
really
okay I might be able to get GPT
to to do this
though cuz I think I've narrowed it down
substantially I don't know what's up
with setup tools
but me
see
where it's installed not where it's
built I'm going to try this I don't
think this is correct
correct but this doesn't even
freaking for
yeah no this is
not this is so
I'm going to try this first and then I
think that this one will work I don't
know why I didn't think of that that's
okay we still get this link
here so this is jippy being stupid as
hell is why I mean if you look at this
this just doesn't make any sense right
now this one though this was potentially
better
I'm trying to think if this doesn't work
work what
else this seems like this should
I don't you can't just
install rib globally
I I'm going to have to do some cleanup
work around this some point soon it's
just the python tooling Sy like
ecosystem is so [ __ ]
yeah we're going to redo a lot of
tooling I think we'll do that though
after I get um all the new
collaborations off the ground and I get
puffer science side efforts into a good
spot I'll do some infra
slow I will also have to look at the
number of assets and stuff I'm bundling
with puffer cuz there are quite a few
um like resource
files it's not terrible it's um mostly
for neural MMO and stuff
but I'd love to get this down to like a
really small package with very few
depths that just installs instantly and
correctly and nobody ever has any
problems with it ever and RL is just
easy that's a
goal okay
[Music]
directory embed the resource B I don't
know if we want to do c23 though Captain
cuz then everybody's going to have to
upgrade their freaking
compiler right so like now just to
install poer you make everybody install
like upgrade their system
compiler like I'd rather go the opposite
and have it make sure it works with
c99 I'm just fixing the package I'll be
able to help you with some stuff later
today uh if you're around oh yeah The
Continuous stuff would be awesome if you
get a chance to do that breakouts fixed
so it's ready for uh for
that not if you publish Pi pie pack well
yeah if you're publishing binaries but
it's you know what a total pain it is to
get binaries to build for all the
different platforms I fought that for
several hours as
well I'm just shipping Source disc at
the
moment oh it's cancer like you have to
have you basically you have to build
your Linux wheel like you have to build
the Linux binaries on like super old
versions of Linux or whatever in
containers so that it will then work on
like anything more modern and then you
just hope that that binary
works it's
awful yes
okay we might be good here
okay that's not necessarily bad that can
be my let's try that again cuz I have a
screw setup here
yes it
works neural mm3
thanks
boom package is working so we will see
whether this is a viable
solution Captain does this make sense to
you or is this going to be super breaks
up this works now it's just I have uh
there's like a permission thing with my
Docker that half the time it it doesn't
pull up the renderer that's like my
system has nothing to do with puffer lip
so this works um the only thing I'm not
sure about
here let me yeah let me show you so I
did this is what I had to
do I set this to an absolute path to get
ray to link correctly because otherwise
it only runs from inside the puffer lib
directory
um GPT seems to think that this is a bad
idea and that
like this can break but the only thing I
can tell is if you move the package
after you install it does anything like
move your packages after you install
them like I would think even in a VM
right if you make a VM
it makes the VN folder and installs it
there okay I'm going to do this for
now
anything
I love when I ship a whole bunch of bad
minor
versions uh because I can't figure stuff
out so
works where did these runs go also here
check check this
out this is what I got working for NYU
yesterday we have hyperparameter sweeps
over GPU Drive running nice and
fast uh integrated with our new
sampler GPU Drive is selfplay
if by selfplay you mean any multi-agent
environment that's training with its own
policy sure it's not a competitive
environment so it's kind of
irrelevant like I'm telling you out okay
competitive multi-agent there's a little
bit of difficulty but like a lot of the
multi-agent stuff is just simpler than
you
expect project name
oh
yeah I mean but the thing is like for
something like GPU drive that's just
what you would do there's not a reason
like there's not a reasonable
alternative thing that you would
do it's not really a competitive or
cooperative environment like the agents
are pretty independent
right ooh this is is not
good
so we have it building locally at least
now and it's just a matter of getting
the uh the Raab
okay so what did this just
do we still have Ray Li here
right this still works okay so it's
almost there
then there's one last link bug
uh let me see if I can figure this
out also why do I have this freaking
screen
um set up
okay I want to see I think it's just
missing raid somehow
welcome currently in Python packaging
hell almost
there there's one last link
bug okay
so and it fails on install as well it
doesn't fail
silently
and actually I'm going to try one thing
car
six I want to make sure I did I got the
right one
think I'm going to move to 3D kernel
policy normal policy can't figure out
first level Beyond randomly hitting it
with Brute
Force I checked OBS and is correctly
handling
actions uh give me some graphs Spencer
yeah give me some
graphs link wanb or Neptune or whatever
you're
using Isn't it nice to just be able to
stream stuff and
immediately troubleshoot user code okay
so very nice speed
like you're not getting a lot of data
back from the environment here
um so I don't know what's up with this
but you see you have like three data
points you should okay so Spencer you
don't just call it when you get the goal
you call it at the end of an episode so
if you reset an episode earlier whatever
you call it then as well um so like
let's say that your goal let's say that
you're you have like you just get a
score of one for completing the level or
whatever you're going to log a score of
zero if it fails to complete the level
in time so then you'll get like a
percent completion rate or
something that will fix your logging and
that will give you clean curves that
you'll actually be able to track because
with this you can't tell anything um if
you get like a clean percentage
completion curve then you'll actually be
able to run a hyperparameter sweep
before you even start messing with
architecture and you'll probably solve
stuff just off of that uh I will look at
these
briefly this is fine this is fine it's a
little high but probably
fine uh it knows the value okay it's not
going to reward that's fine this is fine
yeah so all this stuff looks fine um
I'll check your hypers real quick
massive uh I don't even know how you
have this running fast dispenser cuz
usually this mini batch size crushes
this is usually big enough to just crush
your
GPU uh when you go above like 16k or 32k
usually this just crushes your
GPU I don't know why you have it this
large either because it's not a
particularly long Horizon task um what
you generally do here right so like
let's say you have 496 environments
total right time 32 32 Horizon for
Segment bootstrapping is 131k so like
that's probably good
lambda's kind of
high I would do like 0. n by default
here um but like again you would just
sweep these yeah you reverse these two
uh but 099 is going to be too big for
you anyways like this is not 100 Horizon
task right so uh I would just yeah I
would take batch size down to 131k I
take this down to like 32k or whatever
um if that still keeps your million
performance this is these are weird
numbers like I'm surprised that this
runs this fast with these uh and then
you just what you do is you would use
sweep configs over uh Lambda Gamma
learning rate entropy just those four
parameters and you should be
good you can check the ablation Branch
if you want to try my latest like
Neptune stuff but also you could just
run carbs on it with the default
I would add log one EP yes that's that's
what I told him
already and you just log a score of
zero um and like or like score of zero
for if it doesn't complete and one if it
completes since not long Horizon I don't
need giant batch no Ms well it's not
just long Horizon Spencer it's
like the point isn't how long the
environment goes it's kind of how long
um how like how much data you're getting
out of each step so the thing is that
like the environment's basically
turn-based um so 32 steps is actually
quite a bit of gameplay right but like
if you were doing breakout for instance
breakout probably benefits uh
well I mean not even really to be honest
but like something like breakout where
it's like a high frame rate you could
benefit from longer
segments um impulse Wars could benefit
from longer segments this one shouldn't
need it I thought it was like maximizing
GPU perve well I'm surprised that this
runs as fast because usually probably
it's just cuz your network is Tiny But
when you go this large on the mini badge
size you actually start to crush your
GPU like this is just too much data
being loaded on at once um usually this
is like in most environments in most
architectures this is enough to like cut
your performance by a factor of two or
three just doing this so I assume that
as soon as you like as soon as you crank
up your network architecture a little
bit this will probably just crush the
GPU this is also just like too big
um I mean I guess it's technically
possible that your environment is farse
enough that you need batches this big
but I doubt it I think you're probably
fine with 32 and 131 here and then just
tune the rest of
everything there's your quick review for
now go change that stuff and uh
yeah report back carbs will be good uh
you can try you can try carbs on the
default Branch you can try carbs on the
new Branch whatever you
want oh yeah change the uh before you PR
it change the uh the names to like cstep
C reset C render or whatever it's
obnoxious but it fixes stuff for cond
uh the C functions the the cython
function name stay the same just in theh
right you change it to cstep C render C
reset and then in the scon file you like
update to use those names it's really
really stupid it's um it's a cond
compile bug but it fixes [ __ ] for cond
users I might revert that eventually if
I find a better work
around I've gotten too many reports of
confused users that are all it turns out
they're all just on
cond merge till I have at least one
level beating yeah that's
fine uh yeah yours are fine that's fine
Captain as long as they're
different I like to standardize if we
can but it doesn't
matter all right
uh where was I here
right
so I just pasted a bunch of [ __ ] into
exclude update
it isn't this what I just
did recursive exclude RBS
yeah modify setup.py
it does do this already
okay let me try this one last time
so s
am I dumb like this is being
excluded red star
should I add log if the bot kills itself
yes anytime any time the end ends you
add a
log so if the bot dies if it runs out of
time know any terminal you add a log
and if you do this because the score
gets averaged you know the score gets
averaged for you this will give you
percent uh percent completion rate and
you will get a very nice dense curve
over
time try to add as much logging
info I wouldn't say to go H with it
there is such a thing is over logging um
you know a few good key metrics are
often plenty
the other thing that I've been thinking
about maybe you guys have some input on
um there's kind of an annoying tradeoff
at the moment where with our
logging I average everything in C uh and
because I do that you kind of lose the
granularity of like uh one point per
trial you don't actually have access to
the list of like individual
completions but this is good because if
you
multiprocess then all those infos uh
don't have to go through a socket right
they don't have to go through or a pipe
they just like it's one number so it's a
lot faster
um technically I could make it so that
you just shove like per agent infos
through
multiprocessing and then you aggregate
in the logging layer and then what you
would get is you would get like um you'd
get mean over agents all agents instead
of a mean over
means
which I don't know if that's worth doing
um but it's something I've been thinking
about welcome YouTube
folks there will be more interesting
stuff as soon as I fix this bug
what's the benefit well it would be nice
to have when log to get each point being
a mean over like a specific number of
Agents or whatever uh like for instance
if you're playing breakout uh a mean
over 100 games of breakout would be nice
to do right now all I can do is I can
say hey we're going to get 100 uh 100
logs from breakout but that's going to
be some number of games that's probably
way more than 100
am I blind this is the same thing
recursive
exclude rib
star am I
blind I have this exact line for
I should be able to actually see this
shouldn't
okay that's awkward
um every time I place a
reward I figured it out but it's really
awkward every time I place a reward
uh I should be adding plus equals to
episode return or subtracting in case of
penalty yes or if death hards that
episode return no episode episode return
is cumulative reward it is the sum of
reward over the episode so if death is a
negative one reward you just subtract
one from the episode return you don't
set it you don't hard set it to negative
one
okay so I think I know what's happening
here um
so right here these
files are getting
included
um these files are getting
included and the reason they're getting
included
the nice thing about this is I've
actually I've mucked around with python
packaging enough doing this that I
actually understand most of what I'm
doing here so I'm not completely
blind it's still a total pain in the ass
but
graab I don't know the grad student
start at start at
10 let's
all
so let's
okay so that's going to be a packaging
Quirk
[Music]
um we'll figure that out
separately I'm pretty confident that if
this
works uh from even this directory it'll
work globally
really
okay man this is like fighting back
rayb this is literally commented so I
don't know how
yeah I don't know how this is even there
because it's specifically these two
files
option can I see the files getting
copied
copying I actually don't even see it
here I don't even see the
okay I'm going to try this but because
it keeps but I think this is [ __ ]
stupid
yeah see that doesn't do anything nice
job language models are
okay
there and
last day of antibiotics today speaking
of which I got to go take those in a
second I'm going to finish this and then
I'm going to go get breakfast and do
that supposed to take him at roughly the
same time
I want to finish this build first
though it's like so close to
working so it was doing something screwy
where it was like including old builds
or
something that's just tooling being
dumb
um okay so now we have this
this okay that doesn't doesn't make
sense because it should
be it should have been stalled
RB there's no R lib directory so it
should have installed
okay so I don't know how that's even
possible um
this just straight up not downloading
is it just not downloading it to the
right
yeah it's just not downloading ra
right yeah it's just not downloading ra okay
okay
um yeah that doesn't make any sense to
me
that's
funny X is hiring by just like
please email us your code email us some
good code that you
wrote that is
so and completely [ __ ] worthless um
so
yeah let's get rid of
this completely
worthless nice job
jity complicating my setup for
absolutely no [ __ ] reason um
I this is going to eat messages is the
thing
what the hell do I do with
this I mean this was making sense
the problem is I can't have it ship my
local packages because they're platform
dependent and [ __ ] Mac OS
exists um if this were just straight
Linux I could just include the Linux
ones and be done
I I could technically include both but
that's stupid um there's no reason that
this shouldn't just work
answer just
ship
it's annoying that you get both
versions but ra is really small
anyways let me try this I'm sick of
dealing with this this is just
obscene
um yeah this is obscene
yeah I really got to go down and take my
antibiotics and stuff so I have to take
a break I think this will work I really
wanted to get this done this morning but
let me see I think that this approach
will work it's stupid but it'll
work
um for
okay that works
right that gives you the
okay so the goal here is we just install
the Linux version and install the Mac
version and just bundle them both
um this means that when users install
puffer lib yes they're installing both
but they these are small and also means
that you won't have to go through this
additional error prone download step you
just get the pre-built
files okay and let's see what's wrong
here
wrong this failed
because because what
I don't see what the hell is wrong with
this for
I think this should actually result in
better install times for
users doesn't have to download the
repo I do not know why this is stuck for
so
long I'm going to have to go get
breakfast in a couple
well that's just my OS this is
fine um
works we don't need them the freaking
web assembly in
this let's not make the package huge for
no
reason
copying
that and now we you see it's copied both
Linux
okay uh so we can do car
X okay so now you see that we actually
have Raab in there and now we can
I'm not going to push the package right
now but if this works then what I'll do
is I'll push the code so the CI runs and
then we'll see if that if it agrees that
it actually builds for [ __ ] sake
going oh there's no lib in
there there's no lib
okay uh that's
crazy yeah there's no lib that's
bizarre oh right
here uh this needs to be
include
include uh but that actually doesn't
matter
because it's the lib that's
not
working lib is not
working package data
data not getting
copied let me
see I see the include here
maybe I need to just recursive include
it
actually isn't it just this hold on yeah
hold on I think I'm being stupid I think
I just need
to I think I just need to include
jeez are we done we might actually be
done here
done
okay
here I don't think this actually did it
hold's hold
work
um I'm kind of surprised that it doesn't
system
Linux ABS
path ra Linux
SB and this is RA
um I'm if this doesn't work I'm going to
go up I'm going to just go for breakfast
back it sucks when this type of stuff
happens and you just end up spending
hours but
like what else am I going to do right
this is just the state of python
so I don't know why this doesn't
work there's like some relative issue
I'm going to have to figure out uh I at
least got it to build and work locally
but uh the rest of it I will have to
figure out after uh I'm going to
probably get breakfast do a couple
things go for a walk and I will